i ended up working for another person in
caltech which is in pasadena and um and
she my original boss sarah church she
got me the job with her former advisor a
man by the name andrew lang
and andrew was like he was like this i
don't know like
um
it's like any steve jobs or elon you
know charismatic handsome a persuasive
idea man not the guy always in the lab
you know doing everything but understood
the where things are going decades from
now and he had been involved in
experiment that actually measured the
universe was flat
very close to flat
along with a preceding experiment done
at princeton by lyman page and other
collaborators so the shape of the
universe is flat the geometry of the
universe is flat
how did he do that experiment so he used
the cosmic microwave background and so
what i said is you have to look for
triangles in the universe so you can
measure triangles on earth you can
actually it's hard to show that the
earth is curved but you can show the
earth is curved using triangles mountain
tops etcetera if you have an accurate
enough protractor allegedly yeah yeah
god you you're like auto cancelling this
is great um my ratings are going to show
up man this is going to be great uh if
you want actual signs go listen to brian
if you want all of these conspiracy
theories or a.k.a the truth about flat
earth
so
he what he used was the following
triangle
there are um proto-galaxy sized objects
in the cmb
the cosmic microwave background has
these patches and so you can make a
triangle out of the diameter of one of
these uh blobs of
primordial plasma the soup that
constitutes the early universe which is
hydrogen it's very simple material
understand hydrogen electrons and
radiation very simple plasma physicist
sun understand it
the diameter is you know one base of the
triangle and then the distance to the
earth is the other two legs so he
measured along with his colleagues at
cal tech and then university of rome and
that's other group at princeton
measured uh the angle
uh interior angle effectively very very
accurately and showed that it added up
to 180 degrees can you localize
accurately the patches in the cmb
can you know like where they could like
trace them back location wise you can
know where they are but more than that
there's so many of these patches they're
about one square degree on the sky the
sky you may know a sphere has about
forty four thousand square degrees and a
sphere so there's literally forty four
thousand of these size patches over
which he could do these kind of
measurements to build up very good
statistics that's not exactly how they
do it or how they did it on this
experiment called boomerang but they did
measure very accurately the uh what was
called the first doppler peak or
acoustic peak in the plasma the
primordial plasma that's fast so um
the sphere has 44 approximately 44
thousand thousand square degrees so to
cover a sphere that's a it's a very kind
of important data collection thing when
you're sitting on a sphere and you're
looking out into the yeah into the
observable universe so there's a lot of
there's a lot of patches to work with
yeah and in fact a lot of the fast kind
of algorithmic decomposition of spheres
and and machine learning in the early
2000s still used today was created out
of this field by data analysts using
this thing called hierarchical equal
area uh triangles called heel heel
heel picks is what it's called and just
just stitch all the stuff together and
that's
uh and stitch it together very
accurately yeah get high statistical
significance in order to reduce these
statistical errors very clean signal and
uh measurement device to reduce the
systematic errors those are the two
predominant uh sources of error in any
measurement those that can be improved
by more and more measurement you know
you take more and more measurements of
this table you'll get slightly better
each time but you only win as the number
of the the one over the square root of
the number of measurements but the
square root of 44 000 is pretty big so
they were able to get a very accurate
measurement again it's not exactly how
they did it they also have to do a
fourier analysis decompose that do a
power spectrum filtration windows
there's a lot of work that goes into it
image analysis and then comparing that
with cosmological parameters very simple
model just six different numbers that go
into a model that made a prediction and
one of those is the geometry of the
universe pops out and that is the
universe has zero spatial curvature and
that was called boomerang
you